florence j'ai lu ton bouquin d'ide en
sait quelque chose
ouais c'est embêtant d'écrire des trucs
comme ça
non au bar
ces listes
j'ai pas par rapport à ta famille non
pas du tout mes parents aiment beaucoup
ah ben ouais on se crée la vie tu vas
avec le livre ouais c'est pas étonné
la page page tu peux m'en lire une page
là ok je me trompe pas
en moi dit il dans un souffle à 10
mètres de là le titre passe d'un cul à
l'autre
jp déboutonne mon pantalon sa main
plonge vers mon sexe se tremper et joue
quelques instants avec tous ses désirs
qui lui coule entre les doigts on
humecte le cul et cartes mes fesses
avant tours je suis fait plaquer contre
une paroi de ciment qui a des relents
d'urines le visage vissé au béton et
[ __ ] à fond cette fois ci j'ai juste
un frémissement
quand le bourrelet du gland a passé la
ligne
ma chère c'est elle si vite habitué je
ferme les yeux
j'ai envie de le sentir jouir tout de
suite mes envies aussi d'être labouré
longtemps il y a soudain il nous est
très proche
hayman la presse a continué quand même
s'est entretenu
puis on se le fait à deux et la voix de
jp qui au même instant sort deux mois ce
petit [ __ ] pourquoi pas tient la place
et chaude ça m'apaise sur manu qui me
maintient épinglé à la paroisse
doucement mac doucement prends ton temps
et mènent capote
il ya un flottement des mains puissantes
s'agrippe à mes hanches à nouveau cette
vision extérieure à moi même je vois
comme si j'étais à trois mètres de là
mes fesses très blanche seule lueur dans
la nuit glauque de ce garage et le dos
d'un type que je ne connais pas vers
lequel on ne m'a même pas laissé me
retourne et je sens la petite man brad
caoutchouteuse du réservoir s'appuyer
contre mes fesses et ils s'enfoncent
good gracious l'impression d'être de
nouveau pucelle pas seulement
l'appréhension qui le contractent cela
existe donc des membres pareil il
remonte interminablement en moi et me
plaque contre le pilier comme pour jouir
le comme pour fuir le g monstrueux qui
me forcez me défonce on continue
dérision ou penser à jal est le type me
donne un coup de poing violent dans les
reins et m'oblige à me cambrai me
donnait davantage dans le mouvement
convulsif qui suit il s'enfonce tout
entier les poils de son pubis vienne
raclée ma peau je crie je hurle même la
base de sa queue est si grosse que j'ai
l'impression que mon anus explose je
crie et je sanglote
je commence à aller et venir lentement
d'abord puis de plus en plus fort plus
vite ramenant mélange vers lui à chaque
fois qu'il s'enfonce encore je crie à
chaque fois et puis lubrification de la
capote ou non il coulisse en mois de
plus en plus vite sans peine
j'ai un plaisir étrange comme si je
chier à l'envers quand il est au fond de
moi je marque août pour m'offrir plus à
fond les pensées se bousculent je
comprend bien pourquoi et jp a exigé
qu'il enfile une capote
mais je me désole de savoir que je ne
sentirais pas son [ __ ] me brûler les
entrailles juste un commentaire qui ne
met pas destinée bandai ce bordel qu'est
ce qu'ils étaient trois c'est bon
puis tout se passe très vite il passe
une main devant pour me branler sans
doute tâtonne dans le vide
soudain il arrête ça que mes chemins il
s'arrache à mes fesses et je crie de
nouveau douleur et désespoir [ __ ]
c'est une [ __ ] de nanas se tourner
vers j p va te faire m je me retourne
admis le type est un mulâtre de 25 27
ans il écume de rage dans l'ombre je le
vois des bandes et à vue d'oeil
même ainsi cela que lui arrive à mi
cuisse jp se penche vers moi et me
remontent mon jean
allez viens je me reboutonne il me prend
la main le noir convulsé lance son point
l'instant d'après il est à terre
saignant vilainement de la bouche
jp se penchent que prend par ses mèches
afro et lui aplati la gueule trois ou
quatre fois contre le pilier de béton
bruit d'os et de dents éclaté le type
est tout maintenant
ces gens là quand tu dis ça c'est
incroyable parce que on dirait pas du
tout que tu l'a écrit quoi c'est un
compliment
tu lis ça comme si c'était arrivé à
quelqu'un d'autre
oui
l'écriture c'est la distanciation ouais
mais peut-être que maintenant c'est
arrivé à quelqu'un d'autre pour être
échangé depuis l'époque où tu vivais ça
mais on renaît sur rené un autre ouais
comment ça commence et j'espère en
ouvrant la porte d'une faculté
ouais c'était à la faculté il ya des
profs
ouais on adore cette prof donc s'efforce
de les choisir
alors des fois c'est des questions
d'emploi du temps mais des fois on
s'arrange pour les retrouver et donc
c'est un prof que tu as comment ça s'est
passé entre eux
j'ai essayé qu'il me trouve on n'est pas
complètement conscient les plus
conscients quand on écrit et voilà nous
l'apporté on est dedans amy s'est aperçu
tout de suite que tu allais mais ça
c'est ça ouais paraît que c'est écrit là
ah bon demain qui voit sa n'ont pas tous
les mecs c'est dommage
bon s'épuiserait beaucoup ok y'a des
mecs qui découvre quand il voit une
fille découvre tout de suite qu'elle va
aimer pas qu'elle va aimer ça ouais en
tout cas il y en a un qui l'a vu
et qui on l'a donné à voir il ya déjà
déjà une intuition car l'intuition
féminine est ou non et
c'est étrange parce qu on dit souvent
qu'on rencontre des gens et qu'on lit
tout dès la première rencontre
et en fait c'est pas qu'on lit tous et
qu'on choisit des gens à qui on donne
tout à lire et on s'aide avance qu'ils
sauront peut-être le lire après nous
amène nathalie ça s'est passé comment la
première fois c'était tout de suite très
feutré à l'extrême
ah bah tout de suite on comprend que on
et amener vers autre chose au delà toi
même
il a une emprise sur toi tout de suite
quoi ouais
ouais on choisit
choisi de livrer quelque chose de soi
même sur lequel il va enfin on va tirer
le maximum était amené ou la première
fois
les chevaux ouais
et si tu as fait
il m'a il a ouvert une porte qui était
jamais ouverte
il ya une chanson qui est
de suite des états unis qui dit tu peut
cogner mais tu peux pas rentrer je peu
connu mais tu peux pas rentrer chez la
porte en avant qui ferme et puis après
le deuxième couple s est tu peut cogner
mais tu peux pas rentrer je porte en
arrière qui est toujours fermé voilà
c'est des gens savent connu partout
ouais voilà le début était attaché au
radiateur
non
des radiateurs électriques maintenance
vous peu difficile ouais même les
cheveux et crame non pas le radiateur ça
va être un petit peu surfait on
s'attache tout seul en fait on s'attache
sur l'a10 au péage non s'attache tout
cela soit c'est peut-être ça qu'on
apprend pour moi c'est un des trucs les
plus hard que j'ai jamais eu un geste
passé les endroits un peu comme ça bon
un peu comme ça un peu plus peuplé ouais
on a oublié les figurants c'est bien
d'ailleurs
mais ici la vue est vraiment belle il
donner en pâture à des mecs quoi
ouais mais c'est marrant quand on le
voit comme ça c'est à dire tellement
bcbg
oui on a des masques multiples ouais les
corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus